What's up guys, this is Justin.
The typhoon affected the lives of millions.
Everyone knows I've got the best fans in the world,...
...so the moment I heard about the tragedy a few weeks back,...
...I know I could count on you guys to make a difference.
So I'm looking for you guys to help me help them.
Check out prizeo.com/justin.
In return for you giving back, I'm doing something I've never done before.
I'm bringing a winner to come show him the studio with me next year.
I want you guys to come help me in the studio.
Give me some ideas.
But first, you guys gotta give back.
Help raise money and you can come in the studio with me.
So please, please, help me help them.